I'm feeling kind of just like sad that
was Amanda cludes
on her Instagram story giving an update
on her husband Nick Cordero's health as
he fights for his life in the ICU
battling the corona virus he's in this
vicious ICU dance circle where one thing
goes right and then another thing goes
wrong and then that thing that was wrong
goes right but then the thing that was
right goes wrong since his
hospitalization in March Amanda revealed
the Broadway star has lost 65 pounds
she's also shared that he's battled
multiple lung infections and had to have
his leg amputated Amanda has been
sharing a daily health updates on social
media including Nick's current struggles
there's still carbon dioxide level
problems he's still acidotic and there's
still blood pressure issues so we kind
of really need those things to get
sorted in order to move forward this
latest update comes just days after
cleats shared a lengthy post on what
marked her husband's 85th day in the
hospital saying Nick is profoundly weak
he interacts with his eyes answering
questions by looking up for yes and down
for no he cannot move his body yet
earlier this month Cordero celebrated
Father's Day in the hospital with Amanda
by his side at the time she shared Nick
was quote more alert than I've seen him
in a while no matter what cludes
piss-stained positive so I'm hoping and
I'm keeping the faith that this week
those things happen that we see some
sort of advancement so please keep Nick
in your prayers
[Music]
you